so you've had a few days to sit with it
how are you feeling about being
uh evicted
i would have wanted to stay to fight for
a little bit longer and i would have
been a great
uh i was very loyal to um the alliance
that i
fell into uh
and i know that misha and todrick
advocated for me but unfortunately you
know there was no plan put into place to
back door a stronger player and so it
became my time to leave
and i respect that
that's the game you know it sucks
um
when you talked about uh in your
interview with julie how you felt really
lonely it was also your first time being
the only asian american in a room before
sort of can you describe the emotions
and how you were feeling in the house
i had
i had
exhausted my supply of alliances too
early because um
you know someone blew up my game and
when you're in there and you know that
you're out of alliances it is very
lonely
and uh there was a generational
there were generational differences and
i learned so much all of those women in
there were strong independent moms and
they taught me a lot about
you know
how to be a strong independent woman and
there were there were
many experiences shared like misha um
having her child in her bathroom in
singapore and
these were incredibly strong women and i
respect that so much and
um to hear from celebrities their
first-hand accounts was an experience i
never thought i would have the
opportunity for and so you know maybe i
would have i would have played
differently given a normal season a big
brother with different players and a
different hand but i did the best that i
could and i'm proud of of um
you know walking out and i hope that i
brought was able to bring more
visibility to more diversity and more
minorities being represented in
entertainment
yeah yeah um is there something you look
at your game and you think oh that was
the moment or that was the
the thing that sent you home
uh you know i did i did share with uh my
alliance the plan to backdoor teddy and
that's something that i would have
wanted my alliance to do to tell me
what's going on and to to protect me and
and i unfortunately had to turn on my
alliance for survival
but that was that is how the game is
played and i i know that
uh watching celebrity big brother season
one and the way ross matthews said this
is this is game ross talking and this is
person uh person as a person human being
was talking i knew that i needed to
differentiate
that in the game and i respected that
teddy did what she had to for survival
just as i had to
yeah um you know during the speeches um
you know they say expect the unexpected
and i feel like chris's speech was
definitely that um what did you think of
his speech and did you think after
speech maybe there was a chance you
would have
been able to stay
there was no chance that i was going to
stay once we learned that the
nominations were staying the way they
are because
i heard i heard that the mention that i
am an olympic athlete and it's not
something that i could have lied about
in this version of big brother i could
not pretend to be a bartender and being
an olympian is something i'm so
incredibly proud of and so
uh though i had to leave the big brother
house earlier than i wanted
um
they talked about the super bowl a lot
and i i was i am incredibly excited that
i get to watch the olympics i got to
watch nathan chen's gold medal winning
performance and i'm here for more asian
american representation so what nathan
has done
for our sport of figure skating is
something i truly incredibly admire and
so
though i would have lasted i would have
fought to stay longer in big brother
you know i got to experience nathan's
gold medal winning performance and
that's something that
i so appreciate
yeah it was pretty awesome um
uh
did uh what did it mean to you though
that chris kind of like was like you
know what like she's great she's like
trying really hard like keep her
he
is an incredibly
uh kind human being and i hope it came
across how
how
funny he
truly is he doesn't have to put on that
act he has these witty
one-liners time and time again and the
twitter verse has really given me a
second chance in
being able to experience his humor it's
even funnier watching it through
the it was funny watching it through the
live feeds i'm not sure what happened
with his his early exit but i'll be
tuning in on friday just like everyone
else
yeah and i thought i was going to ask
you about that i don't know what you're
allowed to say or anything but um are
you surprised or the if it is true are
you surprised
um
yeah i think that i think it takes
adjustment to living in the big brother
house you're cut off from technology
you're cut off from music
and
it's incredibly bright in there all the
time i never thought that i would be
someone to wear sunglasses in a house
but i very quickly adopted that same
custom and so
you know they say expect the unexpected
so i can't wait to find out more about
chris katan's exit as well
um
who
would you
who do you think will go far in this
game and who would you like to see go
far in this game
wow what a great question um i think
that misha who i became loyal to in the
game she is incredibly intelligent as
well as physically strong uh it's not a
surprise that she's already won a second
hoh competition and i'm also very much
rooting for carson
he was so likable he's very charismatic
very witty and funny and i admired the
way that he slaughtered us in the first
power of veto competition they are both
two forces to be reckoned with right now
as i said i feel like
misha does have a little more influence
with the vote especially as she is hoh
um
and i
i know that cynthia was up on the block
as well
because um
and and cynthia is carson's ally so
carson's game is a little bit in a
precarious balance
i'm
you know i know that how the game works
i know that if the final to make it
it'll be misha and podrick and right now
with cynthia on the block i have no clue
what's going to happen but i'll be
watching and following very closely
um
if there was going to be another season
of celebrity big brother what
celebrities would you like to see
compete is there a celebrity that you're
like i would just love to see them in
this type of game or environment
misha is so right and the athletes
needed to you know protect one another
so i know that she really advocated for
me and respected how loyal i was to my
first alliance and then when i had to
turn i became very loyal to her alliance
i um you know who i'm who i wanted to
have in the house uh suny lee
simone biles lori hernandez
nathan chen karen chen
all athletes and all
incredible advocates and in their own
way and i think that um
you know
we would have we would have had an
olympic team usa alliance
but i did the best i could um and um you
know i made my mistakes in the game as
well uh but
it was an incredible backdoor
opportunity in eviction night number two
that didn't get taken so we'll see how
the rest of the game plays out
yeah um i look let's start advocating
for an uh all athlete season of
celebrity big brother i feel like one of
the games would be
insane
i feel like they go on forever
i think it would be so incredibly
cutthroat and it would make for a great
season uh if julie does create an
athlete season i'm the first to sign up
for because big brother though it was
incredibly challenging i learned so much
about myself and
if i got to go into it knowing what i
know now i would have played so
differently and you know
it's kind of like you play a board game
you win some you lose some and um
what an incredible opportunity for me to
be the first asian american on celebrity
big brother i was hanging out with true
celebrities and listening to the
experiences
first hand
did i ever think that
an nba player would have a minor
accident
i did not so
lamar and todd bridges talked about
potentially having a podcast together so
i look forward to listening to more
first-hand accounts of uh what happened
to lamar odom that night that tmz
reported about yeah yeah
um
is there like a
um what surprised you the most about
doing this show
music
is
everything to me i
think that relatability is so important
and having music and access to the
outside world and that was a challenge
in itself
but i knew what i was signing up for and
when you're playing a real life game of
that involves strategy and manipulation
and
um
gameplay
wow but what it i
mean you know ryan lochte said that he
couldn't
he didn't he couldn't have prepared for
and
as athletes we love being prepared and
trained and
uh i feel like
it really tested me in ways that i
didn't know was possible so big brother
um would i try again absolutely like as
athletes i think
we just
we love training we love competition and
i'm not a fail afraid of failure so it
was an incredible experience i went out
earlier than i wanted to but
nevertheless i'm so grateful
well the last question i wanted to ask
um was in your speech you did talk about
the cookout alliance and their uh impact
i just wanted to wonder if you could
talk a little bit about their legacy and
why they inspired you so much
diversity is so important to me and
there are so many other minorities that
are fighting for representation in the
entertainment world and i hope that we
can you know unite as all minorities to
advocate for more representation i never
thought that i would be on celebrity big
brother i just never got to grow up
watching people who look like me and
thinking back now on figure skating i
never questioned my
olympic journey because there were
people who looked like me who broke down
the barrier before me just like eileen
goo is doing for
china and and uh
i'm
you know i'm upset that i walked out of
the big brother house way too soon but
i get to watch the olympics now and i'm
so incredibly excited to support the
rest of the players in big brother as
well as
team usa at the olympics
you